antoine bonjour le président russe
vladimir poutine vient de s'exprimer
face aux gouverneurs des régions que
retenir de son intervention
et bien pour sa troisième allocution en
tout juste deux semaines vladmir poutine
a joué la transparence il a avoué qu'il
existait beaucoup d'incertitudes
concernant le semaines à venir
autant sur le plan sanitaire
qu'économique il a déclaré je cite que
certaines pertes ne pouvait être évité
il assuré à ses concitoyens la chose
suivante
la russie a les reins solides et on
entend accompagner les plus fragiles
dans cette épreuve
écoutez nous travaillerons résolument de
façon dynamique et professionnelle
je voudrais souligner que nous avons
tout ce qui est nécessaire
une situation macroéconomique stable une
dette publique minimal une solide
réserve pour les mauvais jours accumulés
au cours des années précédentes des
moyens pour résoudre les problèmes quel
que soit le scénario et enfin nous avons
l'expérience acquise dont la résolution
des crises des années précédentes
il est clair que nous ne pouvons pas
éviter certaines pertes mais nous sommes
en mesure de les minimiser et de mettre
en place les conditions propices au
développement à venir
nous soutiendrons les secteurs
économiques touchés par la crise ainsi
que le marché du travail et le système
de santé et nous ferons tout notre
possible pour aider ceux qui ont besoin
d'une telle aide aujourd'hui
et justement ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin aujourd'hui ce sont tous ces gens
qui ont d'ores et déjà perdu leur emploi
en conséquence de cette pandémie
les indemnités vont leur être accordées
ainsi que le versement anticipé des
allocations sociales aux familles
nombreuses des hausses de salaires pour
les trois prochains mois ont aussi été
annoncés à destination du personnel
soignant en contact direct avec les
malades des ambulanciers aux médecins
spécialistes en passant par les
infirmiers toujours face au gouverneur
le président russe a annoncé l'octroi
aux régions de fonds additionnels pour
la création de lits supplémentaires et
l'achat de matériel médical en retour
l'admirent poutine a demandé à ce que
ces mêmes régions préparent leurs
établissements médicaux et forment leurs
équipes soignantes dans la perspective
d'un potentiel afflux important de
malades car le camp d'un virus trousses
sa propagation sur le territoire de la
russie 8672 cas confirmés pour 63 morts
au total selon les derniers chiffres est
la seule façon pour le combattre à
l'heure actuelle c'est en restant je
cite disciplinés et responsable face à
cette crise merci beaucoup antoine
claireaux pour toutes ces précisions en
direct de moscou font